[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans le débrief du
docte pour ce nouveau numéro on revient
sur le documentaire les cratères de
yamal le réalisateur alexandre panov
s'est rendu en sibérie dans la péninsule
de yamal pour comprendre un phénomène
très étrange depuis 2014 de mystérieux
cratère géant se multiplient et
apparaissent de façon soudaine
les populations locales s'inquiètent
pour elle c'est la nature qui gronde
des chercheurs russes se sont rendus sur
place pour tenter d'expliquer une
réalité inédite alors pour en parler
reçoit gilles grandjean géologues
géophysiciens de formation mais aussi
directeur de programmes scientifiques au
brgm
c'est le bureau de recherches
géologiques et minières bonjour gilles
grandjean bonjour à vous merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation alors pour
commencer en quelques mots votre
réaction sur ce documentaire qu'est ce
que vous en retenez qu'est ce qui vous a
le plus marqué c'est un très beau
documentaire parce que en fait il a dit
deux considérations va dire la
compréhension pour les scientifiques de
ce phénomène qui est quand même assez
extraordinaire qui est très récent et
vous l'avez dit 2014
ces vaisseaux et puis aussi eu comment
les habitants comment les nomades de vie
dans cette contrée
ce phénomène est alors va parler
dernièrement on va voir justement
derrière moi c'est énorme cratère qui se
forment donc dans cette région et
finalement c'est un phénomène vous venez
de le dire à ses récents survenus à
plusieurs reprises depuis 2014 on
n'avait jamais observé de choses
similaires avant dans l'histoire de
l'humanité
alors si vous voulez c'est un phénomène
qui est qui est très liée aux la montée
de la température dans ces pays
arctiques qui jusqu'à présent on va dire
comment dire le pergélisol en fait resté
gelé toute l'année un même année était
du coup j'ai ri salle c'est quoi pour
pour nous explique à tunis au karma
frost en fait ce sont des sols qui sont
qui sont complètement gelé et qui reste
gelé toute l'année
au gré des saisons et pour le coup
depuis 2014 le réchauffement climatique
de commencer à faire monter en
température ce sol qui est à plusieurs
dizaines de degrés en dessous de zéro
et pour le coup ça entraîne des
modifications physiques ou chimiques de
ce sol et d epuis et est composé qui
sont ils sont deux dans quoi alors on va
écouter tout de suite le témoignage
d'une femme de la communauté nenets et
qui vit un dans la toundra de la
péninsule de yamal regarde
avant il n'y avait pas de lacq mais des
mélèzes une nuit il y a eu comme un coup
de tonnerre du type de sol s'est
retournée comme une assiette les mélèzes
se sont retrouvés ciment bas leurs
racines en pendant trois jours il ya eu
cet entonnoir
les gens venaient regarder 14 et
gamecube et le quatrième jour il y ait
un grondement le lac est à gauche de
celui ci s'est vidée et la remplissent
atteint l'utilisent c'est tony pour
boire ni pour les besoins ménagers
dispose ultra dietz nextel ce lac est
sacrée ah non c'est inexplicable
ce n'est pas une force humaine mais une
force de la terre ou du ciel même une
force souterraine qui est à l'origine de
ce phénomène alors des coups de tonnerre
la terre qui tremble on vient d'entendre
c'est assez soudain finalement la
formation du cratère
alors il ya ce qui était observé aussi
dans d'autres cratère lamptey de moins
grandes dimensions
mais c'est finalement la dea et sortent
ce qu'on appelle des éjectas à la
périphérie du cratère crd comme si la
terre avait été soulevée et une partie
c'est vers l'extérieur du cratère et je
me souviens que l'interprétation les
premières interprétations dans les
années 2010-2014 savès avait été de me
dire de faire comprendre ce phénomène
comme étant un cheat
comme si quelque chose finalement été
monté en pression sous la terre et avait
des gaz est complètement en repoussant
la terre de surface sur les côtés et
évidemment l'autre partie s'effondrant
pourquoi ensuite formé une dépression
puis un lac
donc effectivement si le cd des
phénomènes qui sont qui sont assez
soudain du fait même de cette libération
de gaz un pied du en fait à l'affronter
de ce qu'on appelle les hydrates de gaz
mme assez assez nombreux nationaux dans
le temps le permet c'est assez
inquiétant finalement est ce que ce
genre de cratères pourrait se former
ailleurs notamment dans des zones
d'habitation alors dans les zones
d'habitation si les nomades dont ou
effectivement élu domicile dans ainsi
péri dans les dents lisant de permafrost
on ne sait pas a priori se situent ces
accumulations d'hydrates de gaz ce sont
des lentilles qui sont à peu près à une
centaine de mètres sous la surface qui
sont donc un composé qui allie à la fois
du méthane et les molécules aux yankees
en ce méthane et qui sont sous forme
solide en fait tant qu'elle reste à des
pressions et des temples il est enfin
des pressions fortes et des températures
très basses le réchauffement en fait
induit le changement de ce ce solide
date de glace solide 1 en gaz et du coup
c'est ce qui explique cette montée en
pression cette libération soudaine de
gaz qui provoque du coup
ces cratères in fine et ça pour avoir
lieu dans d'autres régions polaires
alors alors d'autres régions polaires
oui joue je crois me souvenir qu'il ya
des quelques exemples au nord du canada
donc il faut bien évidemment qu'ils
aient plusieurs facteurs d'une part la
formation tant d'essais lentilles alors
ses lentilles sans forme comment il ya
des millions d'années
cp région qui était tropicale où il y
avait beaucoup de composés organiques de
la végétation les armes qui se sont
accumulés et cesser ces composés
organiques ont été ensuite enfoui par le
biais de la semaine géologique est un
peu comme comme ça se passe pour le
pétrole en fait il ya une maturation de
ces de ces composés organiques mais qui
se sont produits en fait sans oxygène et
avec des petites bactéries méthanogènes
du coup il ya formation de ce fameux gaz
méthane qui migrent dans le sol qui ce
qui vient s'accumuler pour former ses
lentilles dans des conditions de
température du poti le permettent
survivre à l'état solide d'autant que le
sol reste gelé donc il ya plusieurs le
premier facteur c'est qu'il y ait eu
dans l'histoire géologique du pays cette
accumulation de matières organiques et
le deuxième facteur c'est que ensuite
proposé ce gaz méthane et puis se garder
sous forme solide à une centaine de
mètres sous la surface à cause du gel
qui observe dans ces régions arctiques
là ce qu'on observe maintenant c'est que
ces régions notamment un été un supplice
des températures de plus en plus chaude
et kiki et naître un long de chaleur
pénètre de plus en plus bien dans le sol
et du coup un libé en finalement cette
hydrates de gaz sous forme alors on
parle beaucoup du réchauffement
climatique depuis tout à l'heure mais il
ne serait pas la seule raison en tout
cas c'est ce que dit un chercheur qui
s'exprime dans le documentaire on
regarde
[Musique]
aujourd'hui certains chercheurs
occidentaux essaient de tout réduire au
changement climatique
il affirme que les monticules vont
commencer à exploser et des fissures à
apparaître mais c'est une vision
superficielle
alors oui il s'avère qu'il ya beaucoup
de choses sur le permafrost que nous ne
savons pas encore
plus précisément nous n'en savons pas
beaucoup sur le gaz qu'on y trouve
or finalement quels sont les
interrogations qui restent encore s'il
n'y a pas que le réchauffement
climatique quelles sont les questions
que se posent encore les chercheurs sur
ces cratères
alors il ya enfin cesser c'est un assez
compliqué parce que finalement on voit
que il dépend de certaines réactions
chimiques
donc du coup de la nature de ces de ces
hydrates de gaz alors il ya je les
mentionnaient ils sont fortement composé
de méthane mais il ya aussi toute une
structure de molécules d'eau qui crée
cette hydrate et le garçon solide dont
il ya un effet de température donc et
puis en effet finalement unifie les
mécaniques
c'est à dire comment cette pression qui
a engendré peut arriver jusqu'à générer
un cratère est-ce qu'il peut y avoir des
lentilles plus petit ou plus disséminé
ou plus - aggloméré on va dire dans le
sol et finalement se transforme libère
le gaz et sans créer de dégâts
mécaniques en surface c'est le gaz se
libérant petit à petit à travers le sol
par des petites gens ne rentrent pas
forcément un méga de cratères donc mais
que les facteurs finalement qui
conduisent à l'information
un pédiatre à terre sont quand même
assez particulière donc un comprendre ce
phénomène dans sa globalité nécessite
quand même de ne pouvoir rien bien sûr
l'analyse et de pouvoir le l'idéal
serait de pouvoir avoir le feeling si le
cratère essayer de le remobiliser pour
essayer de bien comprendre tous les
phénomènes
il ya des chercheurs français qui
travaillent sur la question en ce moment
on a vu dans le documentaire des
chercheurs russes 1 qui s'y intéressent
en france
des recherches qui intéresse aussi alors
j'imagine que effectivement des données
de laboratoire de glaciologie ou d'aider
les laboratoires qui étudie les zones
article effectivement c'est des
questions qui doivent se poser bien sûr
parce que effectivement on les bloque
aussi dans le documentaire le sous-sol
sibérien il ya c'est aussi un important
réservoir naturel de gaz avec tout ce
gaz qui s'échappe
est-ce qu'il peut devenir le lieu d'une
production d'une nouvelle énergie
alors effectivement faut aussi noter que
les hydrates on les trouve pas que sur
le continent dans les zones continental
arctique mais on les trouve aussi au
fond des océans parce que ce produit
s'est produit le même phénomène sauf que
l'océan ensuite à recouvrir le tout et
ben l'industrie pétrolière se pose
beaucoup de questions quant à
l'exploitation de ces ressources
effectivement avec toute la complexité
de pouvoir comme je lé d'y arriver a
imagé depuis la surface
le sous sol et et de localiser
exactement les plus grosses lentilles
pour pouvoir ensuite les exploiter les
techniques d'exploitation sont on va
dire assez connue mais il sut le travail
le plus compliqué c'est de localiser en
fait une lentille écuries runes
kantchati j'aurai une quantité
suffisante de hydrate pour être rentable
à d'exploitation très concrètement
comment est-ce qu'on exploite ce genre
de salle alors bon je suis pas un
spécialiste de l'exploitation des
failles les techniques de pardies
solution on envoie un autre gaz qui
permit à l'hydrate de devenir instable
de se libérer finalement le composent et
méthane delà de la structure qui leur en
faire il rate et petit à petit et ça au
moins de sa part à des forages jusqu'à
la surface pour récupérer le gaz ça
c'est bon j'ai j'ai lu quelques articles
là dessus c'est celle des choses qui
sont connues mais je pense que là voilà
le feu
le verrou ce qui est compliqué c'est de
pouvoir les localiser
depuis la surface donc avec des moyens
tu as mangé au physique 1 qui permette
d'imagés le sous-sol et pour pouvoir
ensuite de essayer d'évaluer
on dit des la ressource pour ensuite
mettre en place des moyennes des
plantations
peut-être pour conclure en un mot de
manière générale est ce que c'est un
phénomène qui peut inquiéter pour
l'avenir de l'humanité on a beaucoup
parlé de réchauffement climatique
on a ces cratères qui rend eux-mêmes
terrifie les populations locales c'est
un phénomène inquiétant
ce qui est inquiétant mais ce qu'on
maîtrise peut-être pas trop c'est
finalement ce que vous ayez quelque part
ça peut arriver handball est un peu le
phénomène c'est à dire plus ces hydrates
dégage du méthane qui est un gaz à effet
de serre puis finalement il vient dire
réchauffer réchauffer la planète qui du
coup permis ou permafrost de se
réchauffer de plus en plus qu'ils
libèrent de plus en plus de méthane
quelque part il ya un cercle vicieux qui
peut se mettre en place et finalement il
faudrait s'il sait bien évaluer en fait
cessé libération de méthane arriver à
les quantifier et regarder leurs effets
dans les modèles blogo des vassues en
température sachant que comme je les dis
de méthane régions les régions arctiques
mais continental mais aussi au fond des
océans non on n'est pas actuellement la
quantité totale de ces hydrates située
située au fond des océans ou même dans
les zones arctiques donc c'est très
compliqué d'insérer cette information
d'animaux développement comprendre
réellement leur mba
merci beaucoup gilles grandjean pour
votre éclairage
je vous le rappelle vous êtes géologues
géophysiciens directeur de programmes
scientifiques omeyer gm
le bureau de recherches géologiques et
minières cette émission est à revoir sur
notre site internet
rp france point tv ou comme le
documentaire à les cratères de yamal
merci de votre fidélité à bientôt sur rt
france
[Musique]